listen up you need to stop taking your
education so lightly never the heck is
she talking about now just a stupid
everyday you're late to school and then
you leave early you're always getting
into fights and to top it all off you
have the audacity to sleep during class
[Music]
it's time for you to get your act
together here's the classroom lesson
oh good thank you she rat you see you're
such a big help see that you could learn
a thing or two from Shira EC great moral
conduct top scorers on her tests you
would be wise to try and follow her
example like I'd ever want to be that
boring
[Music]
look it's domina he's so scary whatever
he's just a wannabe pan this sucks I
tried to go to a high school where no
one would know about my reputation but
this place is like middle school all
over again I should have known it was
gonna be super lame
[Music]
oh look it's Little Miss Perfect
[Music]
[Music]
huh what happened that's right I fell
down the stairs wait hold up where am I
is this the nurse's office
[Music]
de metrio okay
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
my body and it's years why on earth
would you go to five leg or about this
sheet right here check out yarmulke he's
like actually studying I wouldn't
believe it if I hadn't seen it myself
question on this one could we substitute
the answers for a and C yes I don't see
why not
in this problems X becomes a so Open
bracket x squared
do you have some serious explaining to
do why am I in your scrawny girlie body
and why are you in mine no idea what do
you mean no idea and how are you so
freaking calm right now we've literally
switch bodies don't you get that I guess
kind of kind of is not an answer I can't
explain why we've switched bodies it's
very strange
however I have a theory on how to return
to normal think back this had to have
happened when we fell down the stairs
together if we were to replicate that
event it's only a guess but it's
possible we would switch back were you
able to understand all that it's okay if
you don't of course I understand I'm not
stupid anyway let's just hurry up and
get this over with it'll have to wait
wha you see if we go right now we'll
have to faint again it may be fine for
you but I can't afford to miss any more
class seriously so what exactly is your
brilliant plan to stay in each other's
bodies forever it's not what I'm
suggesting
as if I'd really want to have this odd
thing between my legs forever
let's wait until after school what
listen we're in this mess because you
tripped and fell down the stairs I'm
sure you can manage for a few hours
hey it's not like I fell on purpose we
on this whole thing really sucks what am
I even supposed to do while stuck in
this dump body all day hold up this is a
golden opportunity
oh crap what should I do
[Music]
it's blows I just want to go back to
normal already uh-huh
so this is where you've been hiding what
are you doing lying in the grass silly
looking for you oh sorry
it's sasaki right you're so funny come
on I brought you lunch today let's eat
together
kiss I gotta play along of course that's
like super nice and stuff thank you for
the food
since I'm in her body it should be okay
for me to eat her lunch right whoa holy
crap this is the lunch of an honor
student
oh yeah I was wondering could I copy
some of your notes from class sure
what the hell why does she have all the
songs of stuff written in her notebook
[Music]
problem
so that's how it is man I don't know if
chicks could be so freaking cutthroat
you know I think it'd be best if we went
back to normal right away what why I'm
sorry it was unfair of me to make you
endure such a horrible experience
[Music]
[Music]
we'll wait to change back until after
school like we said before remember you
told me you don't want to skip class so
we'll wait
also I promise you this once we're back
to normal
I'll make sure those girls never bother
you again mind your own business I never
asked you to rescue me or anything if
you get involved you'll only make the
situation worse
stay out of it I can handle this myself
that thug llamado about nothing much
anyway I've got stuff to do go ahead and
whine - that hopeless loser all you want
it's not like having a delinquent on
your side will actually help huh
we both know what'll happen if he
touches me he'll be kicked out of the
school so fast it'll make his head spin
and yourself
what do you think wait don't tell me are
you actually planning on fighting back
no way if I stop just short then it'll
give her one hell of a good scare and
she'll learn to play nice what's going
on I can't believe you hit me I only
misjudge the distance because your dumb
ass stepped in the middle I told you
look like the road miss stop your
whining
[Music]
man oh man
today was seriously like one of the
worst days of my life the feeling is
mutual
well anyway is this really okay you know
going back to normal I mean what if she
tries to mess with you again I guess
we'll see Hey
but I have to admit it was kind of fun
watching sake freak out the way she did
it's strange but it made me glad so
thank you for your help no problem
what a surprise I never expected her to
be so genuine okay you ready to do this
yes
[Music]
[Music]
with that literal leap of faith we were
able to return to normal except it was a
giant load of crap you it's no use I
don't get it are we really gonna be
stuck in each other's bodies forever
this totally sucks why the weird look I
just realized there is something we
haven't tried yet
what it's written out already on the
stairs we didn't only fall we also
kissed you got to be kidding me right
now why would you go and do something so
stupid I didn't you're the one who
tripped and fell on top of me
regardless we need to test it you mean
here and now we're wasting our time by
not trying hold on are you sure about
this
[Music]
I'm back to normal told you so we are
ourselves again I have to study
hey wait what a weird chick she's
something all right
interesting Jay you ready yes
this is seriously like some Twilight
Zone stuff you know Oh freaking I think
for right now we should keep this a
secret huh I wonder why is it that she
can kiss me without batting an eye hold
up a sec I don't want you kissing anyone
else okay she's jealous we get in
trouble if they found out I took your
makeup exam you know what I mean yeah of
course
some partners Watchi takes my test this
is no life your Shiraishi
it's been a while listen would you mind
coming up to the roof with me so hey are
we still on for a date later today or
what do you agree to go on a date with
this guy where it is you and Yamato
hanging out you know hey boy how to
create a river like that get started I
guess it is crazy I mean why would a
nice honor student like do you want to
hang around with that no-good divi in
any way hey why do you care
hello there again cherish and how are
you feeling today Three Stooges what did
they want
yeah I don't know you look kind of pale
if you ask me I have to agree let us
take care of you
Oh freakin gross you're all so sweet
but I promise you don't have to lie you
want us to take you to the nurse's
office I'd rather die
stay back there I'll teach these guys
nah you said we just had to talk to her
[Music]
who's a liar that roundhouse kick looked
awfully familiar you were faking want to
know something funny I never promised to
go on a date with you to begin with how
about that one which only proves my
theory but you're nice of you to join us
she raised you what's the meaning of all
this please you can stop trying to hide
it besides I have something I'm gonna
show you too
I finished your makeup exam but you
weren't back in the classroom
sorry don't apologize yet I have a
proposition for you guys proposition yep
I'd like to offer you the opportunity to
use this private room sounds shady what
for well don't make it sound pervy the
way I see it you two need a place where
you could safely switch bodies am i
right so you kiss and then you switch
bodies
seriously okay you're obviously a
psychic or something calm down just hear
me out you see not too long ago this
place was originally used by the
supernatural studies club but I'm the
only member and it's on the verge of
being disbanded if you decide to join
you can use this room however you want
there's one tiny condition though you
got to answer something for me be
completely honest have either of you two
ever kissed anyone else what that's none
of your business buddy I haven't just
answer me llamada fine she raised she is
the first person I kissed you were both
each other's first kiss so that means
there's still a chance the thing is I
wonder if it's possible for you guys to
switch bodies with anyone you kiss let's
test the theory sure you see who you
please kiss me the request has been
denied fine I'll kiss ya don't you
freaking dare ain't no way I'm puckered
up for some dude forget about it
actually it would be nice to know go on
wait I do not keep said also what the
hell is up with this weird people hiding
there
looks like we really switch bodies wow
your body is super impressive man this
is so lame so is there an odd thing
between me Maura's legs too cause every
guy has one whoa odd is a good
description for serious breach at the
bro code okay stop that fascinating it
would be interesting if you could switch
bodies with anyone that you kissed I'm
not a damn guinea pig you know just
leave it to me while some may consider
it impossible I'll go find a girl
willing to kiss even llamada I'd rather
you not do that that talk about weird I
wonder why she's against it hold up a
sec okay she is jealous yeah if people
find out about you it could lead to
trouble I really think this is something
we should keep between just the three of
us of course that's what she meant okay
then how about it have you two decided
whether or not you want to join the
supernatural studies club slow down
why are you being so persistent about
your count call look you can use this
room whenever you want and occasionally
you'll help out the student council when
they need it it's a win-win situation
well how do you feel about it Shira is
she I don't mind at all in fact it might
be kind of fun I've never been in a club
before
[Music]
[Music]
fine I guess I'm in is that all there is
okay that settles it from this moment on
we're officially back in business let's
get to it
Jerri she will be club president I'll be
vice president yarmulke holds no office
sure great a jerk you know that
did you just say the supernatural
studies club is starting back up if
that's the case I'm interested in
joining
[Music]
they shouldn't do markup Thanks
[Music]
[Music]
a Amida listen like to kiss your age but
study your business pal
anyway next time on yamato-kun and the
seven witches kiss me okay alright but
you asked me
[Music]